hi I'm Philip my-man I'm an associate
professor of analytics and Finance at
the University of Bridgeport and the
chief analytics officer for Vantage
sports and my talk is about sports &
eSports analytics
the really nice thing about using
mathematic in a new field which is
something I hope you all do is no one
else does it I don't think there's any
other human being on earth who uses
mathematical for my anguish for sports
or eSports and if you can find an
industry or a sub industry or niche like
that boy how great is that for you right
because all of these tools that look
like magic to everybody else are you
know easy for you to do so as I'm
walking through this whether you're
interested in sports or not you can try
to think how you can apply the same
sorts of things to any other industry
medicine health whatever so sports
analytics has changed in the past few
years and if you haven't kept up with it
what you may think is that it still sort
of stuck in the Bill James air of
baseball and using regression to try to
figure out on base percentage and things
like that that was a huge revolution
Moneyball which was about ten years ago
that was a huge revolution it changed
the world to change of the sport people
became more quantitative more analytical
but that is there's only so much you can
do with linear regression right I mean
who are we kidding the future is much
more data it's not just box scores but
like fine grain data points like LeBron
James are standing at this point at this
time then one 125th of a second later
he's moved one quarter of an inch or
whatever I really find grain data for
which you need to be able to add to
manage large scale data and do machine
learning and all other things and
visualizations and interactivity that
mathematic and will from the language
are fantastic at I'll give you some
examples of the stuff that I've built
and you'll see like in any other
language would be virtually impossible
so here's an example so what is the
optical tracking data every NBA stadium
has 29 stadiums 30 teams they have six
cameras located above the court that are
tracking all ten players at the same
time using like this Israeli missile
tracking technology using the center of
mass so you know where everybody is
right happening 25 teams for second so
each game is about 40 mega mega bytes
about 50 gigabytes of data per season
now between us that's not big data right
we're not talking like Facebook
terabytes exabyte pebble or whatever
it's 50 gigabytes but it doesn't fit
into itself
so everybody who's ever been hired in
sports analytics over the past 10 20
years they don't know what to do right
it doesn't fit and how can you visualize
it so here's an example let me actually
if they have it up but I did this work
is you can make little video so you can
interact with it obviously right you can
go this is one play one basketball play
here are the five players on offense the
past they took and you can go back and
forward and see where they were and what
and where the ball is bouncing and who
is it tapped to at the bottom you can do
certain things which is the acceleration
how much the guy is moving per second
acceleration deceleration obviously you
hover over a person that says who you
who it is who's the other guy you can
add the defensive players and see how
they move over time you can add the
referees and see where they are they
actually don't make the referee data
available anymore because they don't
want people tracking referees are doing
referee analytics but you can switch to
a different play you can see what
happened who did what who did what over
here okay great fantastic another thing
you can do so any programming language
could do a 3d histogram fine that's no
big deal but it imagines either of those
plots without the basketball rim there
right it's nothing ready don't really
understand what it is the fact that you
can integrate a graphic that you can
quickly build yourself right here's make
a rectangle make a cylinder make it
whatever suddenly add so much context so
the one on the left just to give that
explain what this is all locations of
all players for that particular season
on the half court where were they and
you can see the coaches have gotten the
memo about analytics one point oh you
should take the long three-pointers at
the wings that's the best place to sit
and take three pointers no question
anyone who disagrees is what dinosaur
like Phil Jackson of the mix right so he
thinks do you think threes are bad right
oh you don't freeze but they're great if
you can get those open shots those are
great shots the rest of the league basic
and Phil Jackson so I'm just kidding
obviously is a huge proponent or two but
what if you is now restricted to places
where people accelerate those are all
locations on the right is where people
are accelerating at least half a G all
of those accelerations and decelerations
don't happen around the corner you don't
just sit not just figured there right
you stand still for the three-pointer
all of your acceleration or deceleration
czar in the paint you're setting a pick
or you're cutting
to the basket so you can compare those
two of them together not me quick I'm
again just a very quick rundown of a
bunch of other tools you can build and
think about how how much interactivity
and visualization ads you're trying to
communicate to general managers and
owners who historically don't really
understand analytic they don't trust
analytics I think it's trying to take
their jobs they think you're a nerd and
they're a jock there's a huge clash but
if you can give them a tools that they
can extract the information that they
wants that they can keep asking the
questions so you want to want to make
the cycle of question asking and
answering really short right now in most
organizations occur in any industry in
any industry your industry in your
business if you have a question about
your data usually take that least a day
it's not a week to get an answer right
let's look at all of our bank branches
and see which customers have been with
us the longest for each particular
branch okay so certain SQL query but you
have to got find the guy who knows it
gets the data gets SQ already done if
you want to visualize it that's another
three weeks now suppose you get an
answer back now you want to say oh you
know I wanted to change it a little
filter forget it you're at some point
you're not even going to ask the
question anymore right just take too
long to get an answer but if you have a
tool like this this is a rebound where
the rebounds go you see the rectangle
this one's mine interactive approach is
just a snapshot but if you in the real
world it is interactive so you put that
rectangle anywhere you want here's
another example and you can see where
the shots taken from that rectangle
where they end up where they're
rebounded right for missed shots so if
you're taking from the left wing most of
the shots you can see where the rim is
it tends to go to the other side and
this is a rule of thumb that basketball
people have known for generations right
if you're gonna position for rebound
sixty percent of the time it's going to
go on the opposite side but now you have
exactly right if you're drawing up a
play it's nice to know that if I have a
great three-point shooter on the wing
where should I locate my best offensive
rebounders well it should be about six
feet out from the rim whereas if you're
taking it here then it's more spread out
and you have the colors you can hover
over it and they'll tell you can click
and they'll say this is the shot that
happened years was taken by who here who
is rebounded by and now a coach that
isn't reliant on you there's no more
friction between oh my god this
analytics guys telling you stuff I don't
wanna hear no now it's all this this guy
whoever he is you built me a tool i have
a tool great now i can ask any question
i want i can design whatever I want
whatever play I want here's another
example for shooting
all these lots of different things you
can you could do with it but tons of
this is just a distance from the the x
axis of the distance away from the hoop
that you are from the rim and what is
the average for all the people chosen in
that particular year of their field goal
percentage their effective field goal
percentage so three-pointers count one
and a half times as much as regular
field goals so you can see the best
thing is to dunk it surprise surprise
right if you're right there and you put
it in good for you you have about a
seventy percent chance of getting it in
because obviously some defenders there
and everything then it drops off sharply
till about ten feet when it's flat for
about twenty that's the mid-range game
that people tell you you shouldn't
really rely on right because that's
about a forty percent field goal
percentage not very good but then you
take a step back and suddenly that big
gap those are three pointers wide if
you're still shooting the same
percentage where you're getting fifty
percent more bonus or you put things
visually like this who can argue you can
feel Jackson you can look at one shot
how it felt how later led to another
shot or look at all of the makes where
they tended to happen just the frequency
thing this is the most complicated thing
I built it to pull steps it's way too
complicated but the basic idea is when
you're doing a post up how did you get
the ball was it passed in or did you
dribble in and back up when you shot was
it a make like a green or miss with
three red or a pass out with a blue
where were you on a left block right
blog post points per possession these
kinds of interactive tools imagine
building us for your industry for your
clients for people that you work with
right if they can get their hands on it
boy you're you're doing a great job
because then you're not providing
answers you're providing tools and
everyone loved the tool provider here's
another example so this is a paper I
wrote that provided everything online
for free it automated general managers
it makes general managers dinosaurs a
thing of the past they should be
replaced with robots right because if we
have machine learning as better humans
and chest in jeopardy in go right now
deep learning would go at citgo is
solved forget it but no figuring out
which athletes to put on the court that
beyond the scope of any computer program
on earth right that's way too
complicated it's not it's very sit the
interesting thing about mathematic is
the hardest parts that you would think
of objectively you might think all I
have to make
complicated machine learning well that's
one line right it just classified pick a
couple parameters everything else is
just presenting the information
convincing people here's how much you
lost out because you didn't follow this
model you can you know if you drastic oh
okay machine learning here's a problem
with machine learning not a problem with
a problem a problem with machine
learning is at the black box right
what's the biggest thing I can't use
your machine I don't know what's going
into it with the regression it's
beautiful I know exactly what what each
coefficient is how much you contribute a
black dog don't know what's going on you
do know what's going on here's one way
you can tell people what's going on you
build a model and then you show them the
inputs these are all the inputs right
how old the guy is how many games he's
played in business from college bridge
what was his wingspan was a-standing
reach his max vertical general position
as they play all that stuff fine and it
tells you this is for Kawhi Leonard who
is he most similar to back when he was
drafted who what is it is projections
great black box not a black box because
if you make each one of these editable
just a simple drop down menu right now
you can suddenly get anyone it's a tool
and you can see well what if I don't
believe in a particular number of them
if I think his defensive windshear
should have been not 4.6 but 3.2 which
is the third quartile I'll click it I'll
get a new number oh now I get a sense
now it's a push back right now I have
this in it's a real emotional connection
to the models no longer a black box it's
my black box and I can understand my
black box and fiddle with it that makes
sense I think building a tool like this
just a one-off Pricer going from your
input to your outputs where you can
adjust them with knobs or however you
want now people can believe it right it
doesn't feel like magic it just feels
like I don't understand everything but
for the particular guys if I have a
different belief i can I can see what it
looks like let me go to eSports now does
it go so another nice you could build
tools like trades right type in people's
names or whatever it's like a little
menu button it can evaluate everything
for you I'll let's do some eSports who
here has heard of these sports oh good
for you so eSports I hadn't heard of
them a year ago I mean you kind of hear
what is that video games people playing
pacman or something right no these ports
are huge it's huge if you've never heard
of an overview these kind of things just
video games no this is an industry
in a few years or decades at some point
it will overshadow all physical sports
stadiums get sold out where people come
in pay a ticket buy popcorn hot dogs
beers and watch the computer screen they
watched five people here five people
there typing and pounding away and you
just watch what happens most games are
interactive team game the typical look
at the biggest game the biggest game
involved league of legends anyone here
with play League of Legends yes what's
your rank nice LeBron James could work
in my way up Gold is very good bronze is
where most of the garbage players are
like me so here you're a good player
League of Legends is a five-on-five game
where you're playing in three different
lanes I kind of like capture the flag
you have to get some objectives and so
on but and you can confirm this the
analytics for League of Legends are
ridiculous all you really know is how
many kills you got how many times you
died now how many towers you got really
really small level stuff so one of the
things we've been doing advantage is
creating all sorts of new data and then
analyzing it so here's one nice way of
looking at things one important thing
when you're creating is team is your
team composition how do you work
together with your teammates this is an
example we partner with a lot of
professional teams for all of the
compositions we can figure out which
one's your best that look how nice this
graph is this is about a couple lines of
Mathematica code right it's a pair to
histogram and you put a little things
over here by the way if you've never
tried something like this the way this
works is on the right you have the total
number right so you have 17 tank for the
red team vs 13 tank I mean that the net
for so you put the floor in the middle
now you could easily visually scan down
and see who's winning what because
sometimes appeared histogram you can't
really tell immediately which ones
bigger we've also created a win
probability model live in-game you tell
you can tell how many times you've died
and they've died how many turrets you
took how many dragons whatever and
immediately tell you you have a
probability of winning a 45-percent this
is really useful up a 20 minute mark
because that's the earliest you can
forfeit so if your probability of
winning is like six percent at that
point you can tell your teammates in the
vehicle case I play another game this
would be now much easier with version 11
because you can make call out you can
see or how your win probability is going
changing over time right what was the
big jump down what was the big gap up
what happened
the most the biggest takeaway though if
I could tell you is what I end up doing
with Mathematica a lot for all sorts for
finance for analytics for everything is
doing the back end where the machine
learning whatever but then providing a
website so providing sometimes the cloud
the ploy kind of thing where its
interactive fine but sometimes it's just
pre computing a lot of different
graphics and packaging them so they look
nice together so here's one example put
it in a different this is a game I
played in July a t-mo if you know you
know teemo's cancer everyone hates chemo
he you know he people like killing timo
and I give them that opportunity by
dying a lot all of this stuff this is an
entire website right it just made for
Mathematica just runs on the back end
spits out all the stuff and then
incorporates just a template of a simple
index dot HTML and you know makes little
videos whatever you want this is how the
fog of war has changed what you've seen
what they've seen again none of this is
available anywhere else but with
mathematic it's pretty easy to do so let
me give you another example so if you if
you're in a team fight this is not data
you can get from the core riot of league
of legends or anything so here I'm a one
guy against two guys you can click
through and it shows me all the times
I've died so let's look at one time is
this a 13-second videos me dying I'm a
little guy chemo right there its variant
the judgment that's me so I'm just kind
of wandering around everything looks
fine it's oh my god two people maybe
I'll make it out you think I'll make it
this time come on little dude come on
you can make you just get a little more
ah that's it that's one tool what other
examples oh so someone sometimes you can
build a tool that incorporates box this
is a cloud deployed version let me show
you an example of this so you put in
your what's called a summoner name of
your in-game name what's your name in
the game right you don't really have a
real human name the first thing is is a
forum page so it spits out just to list
of your recent games okay so let's look
at my recent game I was again a t-mo
what this is doing now this is just a
series of hyperlinks in the forum page
but each hyperlink links to another API
crowd deployed which itself goes out to
a bunch of
website to get the professional build
how would a professional have played
Teemo and compares it to how I actually
played team oh here's what the
professionals would have purchased in
terms of their items and here's the
garbage i bought instead i'd say oh i
got 11 right basically out of six right
I'm terrible I'm a really bad play i'll
never be gold i hope someday but another
one this one takes no time but the basic
idea behind this one is you can put in
so you have different people you're
trying to make a team all right let's
let's outfit so suppose we were able to
play together actually right won't even
let its rank up together because we're
he's too good right you have to be
within like one tier I can't even play
with him maybe someday but if you're
playing with five people you put in
their names here together you'll see
it'll automatically go through all their
history what are your most favorite play
champs and of those all of those
possible combinations which ones give
the highest win probability so now you
know what you should play against the
other team we've built other tools based
on drafting and banning and all these
other things where again the the hard
stuff the hard stuff oh I'm a chief
analytics officer I have to go sit down
and think about model it's one line
right it's classified it's nothing the
the hardest part is making the website
look pretty right put the icon here make
a little bold you know here's so here's
an example of that whole paper I put
about automated general manager
everything is free online now no GM has
an excuse not to not to have an
excellent team let me the last thing I
want to show you is will do something
live to some lies eSports analytics so
part of this I've already done but then
we'll try something I've never done one
quick thing you know so sometimes you
want to do classify on every possibility
right what all the methods the simplest
way to do that is you go to classify
find all the methods where they were
there they ever hear they are selected
it makes a little list right same as
that you paste it in you get the first
of each one and boom you have the lift
that's the nicest way to do it training
and test data let's analyze the classify
for every possible method now you may
notice the drop minus two and think of
what's going on for some reason random
force breaks in 11.1 it just shuts down
the whole kernel I don't know what's
going on a little too random and forth
alright so and it's modern exposed
almost done in some support vector
machine which is last one and we can see
how accurate precise they are and the
confusion matrix plot so we're looking
for a diagonal is really deep red and
everything else kind of not so much red
let's say it looks okay so orange is
good too so 1500 versus 300 the accuracy
is eighty-five percent you can see it's
good across both the markov didn't do as
well it's very more like sixty percent
remember so what are we trying to
predict here i should have mentioned
this is all the stats that we care
accounted for one particular guy when
he's playing a game at the end of the
game he has a certain amount of kills
certain amount of deaths or medicine
certain out of words that he's placed a
certain amount of minions that he's
killed a lot of different statistics but
he's just one guy out of 10 on the rift
threads of the fields of justice where
the game is played one guy out of 10
it's like looking at one basketball
players end of game statistics and
trying to predict whether his team won
the game right you can have a great game
you want you but you but you lost right
michael jordan was famous for doing that
then he started winning so about a grand
as far as most winning is player so it's
amazing getting fifty percent is trivial
right Quinn flip getting sixty percent
is not so great but you can get eighty
percent all right great any questions